okay so welcome to this video you
playing giltch and guys the banker you
know it's not like winning four black so
you can actually play it but they'd
rather play this kind of things it's
solid of course okay before I can take
little bit awkward night if for lets the
bishop pair of it if it's not not that
great
there you are you can immediately regain
the bishop pair so it doesn't really do
all that much okay okay earlier 94
Bishop takes Bishop takes Knight a form
as possible and just never there's too
many trades for my taste I don't know g4
maybe not a threat but one job yeah some
are unbalanced this a little bit from
maybe 90 for the night a four is good
not a big problem probably I should have
probably prevented them
the the move adverse me is c5 that looks
a little bit whoa
it doesn't work I think but it still
shocks a little bit
I can go to yay okay here he threatening
made in wanna move I should definitely
have this on the radar so yeah I mean
this is not this is not objectively
working for white but it is that rather
dangerous one problem is that my pieces
are not so active kantipur but this is
this is nice yam that I get this check
actually yeah and Knight f6 next this is
good I can actually defend actively him
Queen age 8 now is ridiculous because of
King d7 so he has to go back and then I
can maybe get some maybe I should have
played Queen f2 actually Queenie a 3 now
is still it's still kind of
kind of messy yep definitely messy maybe
d5 here 225 takes 10 things got f5
Kingda settle not threaten should reform
but I don't know still doesn't look like
very M very easy
ND get your iphone and so yeah we should
probably not played the night Dan so
quickly yeah come on playing it or
whatever okay it's the only move heads
yes f5 you know he had at five he and at
five I forgot about it right okay this
is also not clear or anything but um
it's been a pretty long session is
sometimes really see complete nonsense
after playing for a while yeah I should
have entered with the Queen instead of
9006 that really was was quite a lot
better yeah now I'm look up but I don't
know if it really means anything my king
is extremely exposed I mean okay
extremely exposes is probably a little
bit bit of an exaggeration it's not that
bad and I have some counter play the
night years pretty bad as well so we
should bishop ever three or something
looks good I can also start with this
move yeah this looks good actually
attack the book
and I have I have some funny ideas here
Bishop e3 stuff like rookie one is the
most normal-looking move we should have
three maybe if you take syd Queen d2
this good this is nice actually it's
nice let's do it and Queen d2 should
finish things
he doesn't have checks him nothing
meaningful I think big mess this game
yeah i blundered f5 earlier
I think he has a meaningful check Luke
g1i t group g8 King f1 and I should be
made I didn't didn't calculate your mate
but there should be one with rook and
queen attacking there's always some kind
of maidens this type of position so it
should check should be check should be
enough so I can also start with this one
time warning king of to print you one
checking YouTube you to check their
there and this made yeah check check
check check Kings III is me and here I
just assumed this one and yeah there's
this check check check mate there was a
meeting yeah I was a complete mess so so
let's just look from here yeah this is a
sudden you like all that much but and
then all the sudden he played this war
like where's the cold bolt from the blue
can you really tough to believe it's
difficult to play of course for black
but still I have my doubts so f1 Knight
f6 actually immediately and not the
czechian don't check but it's the check
bad seems worse according to the company
even though I mean this is not a great
depth so here
what is the big difference thats that d
5 is better now yeah this is an idea
that has had seen earlier with senior
later in the game if I get this in its
grade of course yeah this is the engines
main line maybe there is nothing else
here this wasn't I think all that great
in the game okay ya hear I was actually
thinking but he has a five yes yeah that
this could be an idea and the engine
gives that actually at 59 f 6 check this
I didn't see that i'm jang up a pizza or
King takes e that's crazy and the queen
is strapped but that's rookie one
equality okay this is what I did look
before I nope yeah this is crap due to
f5 and I saw it and forgot about it yeah
and d5 was also something ahead on the
radar but as somehow it felt to me like
it shouldn't work even though i'm not
quite sure what it was when I didn't
like hmm I you know this is this one I
didn't like but the engine just goes
back and says everything's cool yeah
yeah once you see it you kind of
appreciate it but yeah this is just
ridiculous movie can go by five yeah
things are you have where he has to go
to III m no to d3 yeah it's a complete
mess here should be a winnable sugar 3
does win so I calculated this one this
one correctly at the end well what a big
mess thanks for watching